Il existe un endroit où les vestiges
archéologiques les plus extraordinaires
sont encore largement inconnus du grand
public.
Un endroit où le désert est habité depuis des millénaires,
où les civilisationsse sont succédé et ont laissé des témoignages inestimables
mais où beaucoup reste à
découvrir.
Cet endroit, c’est Al-Ula.
Située dans le Nord-Ouest de l’Arabie etencore en marge du tourisme international,
Al-Ula devrait être accessible aux visiteurs du
monde entier dans les années qui viennent.
Il faut dire qu’avec un paysage époustouflant et des
vestiges archéologiques absolument exceptionnels,
tous les ingrédients sont réunis
pour en faire un haut lieu culturel.
Je vous emmène donc découvrir cette région, et
visiter les fouilles qui s’y déroulent en ce moment.
Et nous sommes très heureux de vous offrir
ces images en exclusivité sur Passé sauvage.
Al-Ula est une vallée située à 700 mètres
d’altitude, et environ 150 kilomètres de la Mer Rouge.
C’est un corridor naturel dans
les montagnes qui a été emprunté à toutes
les époques pour le commerce, les expéditions
militaires ou le pèlerinage vers la Mecque.
L’environnement géologique est
assez remarquable. Les massifs
de grès sont érodés par le vent et les pluies,
et dessinent des formes étonnantes.
A l’ouest, ils sont surmontés de coulées de lave, qui ont
figé la montagne sous le basalte.
La vallée, au centre, forme une vaste plaine de
sable. Le climat y est très aride,
puisqu’il tombe en moyenne moins de 100 mm
de pluie par an,
pas de quoi faire pousser grand chose.
En fait, les humains ont
pu s’installer ici grâce à un aquifère,
une grande nappe d’eau qui se trouve à dix mètres
sous le niveau du sol.
C’est grâce aux nombreux puits dans la vallée qu’une agriculture d’oasis
a pu se développer depuis plusieurs millénaires.
Les premiers habitants de la région sont pourtant
bien plus anciens que l’adoption de l’agriculture.
Sur les plateaux volcaniques à l’ouest ont été
retrouvés des pierres taillées du Paléolithique
inférieur, qui témoignent des premières sorties
d’Afrique du genre humain il y a plus d’un milliond’années.
Bien plus près de nous, à partir du VIe
millénaire avant notre ère, des cairns funéraires
sont élevés par des populations de pasteursnomades.
Plusieurs centainesde cairns ont été étudiés à ce jour
mais ils ontlivré très peu de mobilier à cause du pillage etdes réutilisations
aux périodes postérieures.
En bas, dans la vallée, ces premiers peuplements sont visibles grâce aux gravures sur la roche.
Dans le vallon de Jabal Ikmah, ces gravures couvrent pratiquement
tout l’espace disponible.
Lieu sans doute investi d’une fonction sacrée,
il a été fréquenté à toutes les époques.
La chronologie de ces représentations est très difficile à déterminer
mais certaines gravures du site sont très
vraisemblablement contemporaines des premières
occupations néolithiques, en particulier celles
qui montrent des animaux disparus de la
région comme les aurochs ou les autruches.
Toujours au néolithique, mais 200 kilomètres
plus à l’est
ont été érigés des monuments très mystérieux
ce sont les mustatils
ce qui veutdire “rectangles” en arabe.
Ces grands espaces délimités par des murets de pierre,
et quipeuvent faire jusqu’à 600 mètres de long,
devaient probablement avoir une
fonction religieuse. Un programme
récent en a étudié plus d’une centaine et
réussi à obtenir une première datation,
à 5000 avant J.-C. Les recherches futures
viendront sans doute préciser cette chronologie.
Aux époques postérieures, c’est une véritable
société sédentaire qui s’installe à Al-Ula.
Quittons donc la Préhistoire pour aller
découvrir les vestiges de l’Antiquité qui
font la renommée de la région.
Je vous emmène àDadan, le principal site antique de la vallée,
capitale des royaumes dadanite puis lihyanite au
premier millénaire avant J.-C.
Nous y retrouvons  le Docteur Abdulrahman Alsuhaibani, professeurd'archéologie à la King Saud University,
et consultant auprès de la Commission
royale pour Al-Ula.
C’est lui qui dirige les fouilles actuelles de Dadan dont l’enjeu
est de mieux connaître les origines du site.
on se trouve au milieu du site de Dadan en fait
on est vraiment au milieu du temple, du sanctuaire
l'université roi Saoud a fouillé ici et ils ont
vraiment dégagé un temple dédié au dieu Dhû
Ghaybah le dieu principal du royaume dadanite et
lihyanite maintenant le projet archéologique la
collaboration entre l'arabie saoudite et
la france on reprend les fouilles ici à
pour bien comprendre la stratigraphie
du temple et pour bien comprendre même le plan dusanctuaire
les trous qu'on voit derrière nous
sont considérés comme des tombes
elles datent apparemment vers 5e-4e s. av. J.-C.
bien sûr elles sont réutilisés plusieurs fois
Ces tombes ont été faites pour la haute société
avec une fonction très élevée
le propriétaire des tombesaux lions était minéen c'est à dire du Ma’în dusud d’Arabie
comme le lion est un animal très
fort donc c'est un symbole en fait de protégerces tombes
malheureusement les tombes qui sont
creusées sont vidées vers peut-être vers la fin
du 19e siècle ou peut-être 20e siècle
donc on
n'a pas trouvé des squelettes mais on essaie
toujours de trouver des tombes avec des squelettes
pour comprendre en fait les pratiques funéraires
au milieu du 6è siècle av. J.-C. Nabonide
le dernier roi babylonien envahit Dadan et tue
peut-être même son souverain le vide laissé dans
la région profite alors à une tribu installée plus
au sud les lihyanites qui prennent le contrôle
de l'oasis d'Alula
on a beaucoup d'inscriptions qui documentent parfaitement l'arrivée du
roi babylonien l'arrivée des lihyanites au
pouvoir politique
et on sait bien que comme a
le grès derrière nous et les montagnes de grès
ça facilite en fait l'écriture donc on a plein
plein d'inscriptions il faut savoir par exemple
qu’ici à Alula on a neuf types d'écriture on a
les inscriptions qui s'appelle les inscriptions
dadanites, les inscriptions thamodiques les
inscriptions nabatéennes les inscriptions
grecques, romaines, araméennes, sud-arabiques, arabes
un lieu de rencontre entre les civilisations
Alula se trouve sur la route du commerce
qui vient du sud d’Arabie vers le nordd’Arabie
alors le commerce à l'époque c'était
basé sur
l’encens, la myrrhe et les épices mais
l’encens a été la richesse remarquable à l'époque
l'homme qui a vécu ici a tout ce dont il a besoin
Dadan était donc la capitale de royaumes
locaux originaux, et qui sont encore loin
d’avoir livré tous leurs secrets. Mais la
région a aussi été pendant l’Antiquité,
dominée par un pouvoir bien plus connu du grand
public.
Pour en voir les vestiges, il faut se rendre à une vingtaine de kilomètres de Dadan
tout au nord de la vallée d'Al-Ula
à Hégra
Hégra, c’est le premier site saoudien
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de l’Unesco,
et sans aucun doute ce qu’il y a de plus
spectaculaire dans la région
Le site était en fait au Ier siècle avant notre ère, l’extrémité
sud du royaume des Nabatéens, dont la capitale
était la célèbre Pétra, en Jordanie.
C’est pourquoi on retrouve ici la même architecture des tombeaux rupestres à façade monumentale.
On sait aujourd’hui que les tombeaux monumentaux
ont été taillés entre l’an 1 et 75 après J.-C.,
mais certains sont utilisés jusqu’au IVe siècle.
On en compte une centaine environ, tous réservés
à une élite sociale. Ils étaient sculptés de
haut en bas, sans échafaudage, et l’excavation
d’un tombeau était l’occasion de récupérer des
blocs de pierre, utilisés ensuite en maçonnerie.
On le voit bien ici au pied du Qasr al-Farîd,
resté inachevé, les pierres en bas de l’édifice
n’attendent plus qu’à être détachées de la paroi.
Le creusement d’un tombeau, façade extérieure
plus chambre funéraire intérieure, devait
prendre en tout plusieurs mois, peut-être
jusqu’à deux ans pour les plus imposants.
Ces chambres mortuaires étaient interdites d’accès
dans l’Antiquité, des inscriptions au-dessus de la
porte le rappellent souvent d’ailleurs. Elles ont
permis de comprendre que les Nabatéens parlaient
sans doute une langue apparentée au vieil
arabe, mais utilisaient l’écriture araméenne,
un alphabet de vingt-deux signes, qui s’écrit
de droite à gauche.
Les nombreuses inscriptions d’Al-Ula documentent avec
précision la transition
entre l’araméen et l’alphabet arabe moderne.
Au fil des siècles, la forme des caractères dérive
petit à petit pour adopter celle qu’on lui connaît aujourd’hui,
c’est un témoignage capital
Au-delà des tombeaux, il existe sur le site
des espaces de banquet funéraires, eux
aussi creusés dans la roche.
Les nombreuses gravures et inscriptions qui les accompagnent
témoignent de la longue fréquentation des lieux.
"On dirait une main"
Ces tombeaux ne sont toutefois que la partie la
visible de l’occupation du site.
"là y'a de la couleur encore"
Au centre de ces  massifs de grès sculptés s’élevait autrefois
la ville d’Hégra.
Elle était construite en briques crues qui ne se sont malheureusement pas
conservées. Les prospections et les fouilles ont
révélé une ville de 52 hectares, entourée
d’un rempart de trois kilomètres de long.
Au Moyen-âge, la vallée d’Al-Ula est
intégrée dans l’empire musulman dès
son origine. Al-'Ula devient rapidement
une étape importante sur la route du
pèlerinage de la Mecque depuis la Syrie. La
vieille ville d'Al-Ula date de cette époque,
elle est mentionnée par les textes des pèlerins
depuis le XIIIe siècle. Construit en terre et
bois, ce labyrinthe de ruelles abritées était
surtout habité l’hiver, puisque pendant l’été,
les familles rejoignaient les palmeraies et
les potagers disséminés dans l’oasis.
Située à l’endroit le plus étroit de la vallée, la
ville surveillait aussi le passage grâce à
la une citadelle construite sur un éperon rocheux.
Les fortifications visibles aujourd’hui ont été
bâties pendant la période ottomane et la terrasse
du fort délivre une vue imprenable sur les toits.
En cours de restauration aujourd’hui, la vieille
ville fournit un témoignage précieux sur la
vie quotidienne des populations qui y ont vécu
jusqu’aux années 1960.
Ces habitations modestes sont un complément saisissant aux fastueux
tombeaux de l’Antiquité.
Mille fois moins spectaculaires ou grandioses,
ces ruines modernes
sont pourtant presque plus touchantes.
Abandonnées à leur sort il y a quelques décennies,
ces constructions retrouvent désormais,
et c’est tant mieux, toute leur place
dans le patrimoine historique d’Al-Ula.
Je remercie la Commission royale pour
Al-Ula qui nous a permis de filmer sur
place et faire découvrir au public de la
chaîne ces images inédites. Et je remercie
encore le Dr Abdulrahman Alsuhaibani de nous
avoir accueilli à Dadan dans ces conditions
particulièrement privilégiées. La poursuite
de ses recherches promet assurément de grandes
découvertes qui révéleront encore davantage toute
la richesse archéologique d’Alula et de sa région.